and now that the award for sound effects
editing these are people who put all
those sighs and whispers and moans in
the proper signals and the nominees are
Steve Annette flake and Richard Shore
for cashing cars crashing elevators
crashing bodies in die hard
Charles L Campbell and Noel Eden for
helping to make Roger the most popular
rabbits and Harvey and who who framed
roger rap band fruit and Richard Richard
Hynes for transporting us to a world of
medieval magic and sorcery and Willow
Oscar go to Charles L Campbell
what a lovely beginning to the evening
ladies and gentlemen the Academy we
thank you from the bottom of our hearts
my family we would like to say a word I
remember the first time Chuck and I
screamed Who Framed Roger Rabbit
there was a maze of pencil tests actors
acting with no one
sometimes on empty stages after the
screening Bob Zemeckis turned to us and
said guys trust us we think we know
we're doing it obviously he did on
behalf of myself my partner Chuck and
the sounding crew I would like to thank
Bob Zemeckis Amblin while Disney Studios
for this great opportunity to my wife
Pat and kids clear the mantle the 61st
annual Academy Awards continues after
this